spring sand amick does a great job
covering the NBA for USA today Sam joins
me here on the show so Sam what's the
latest that we know about the Kyrie
search Kyrie Irving situation in
Cleveland Chris I even listen to me it's
it's one of the things it's not
expressing from a PR standpoint it's
pressing from a you know the optics are
not good I don't think the Cavs you know
I have a pressing need to do a deal
right now and you know they you're
talking about a guy that that is a star
in this league and a guy who you've got
to get maximum return and so you gotta
be patient and so you know the clock is
ticking though because training camps
around the corner that's what the human
component comes into play right where
the idea of him sterling in the camp
looking LeBron in the eye and you know
and the rest of those guys and and
moving forward with that is extremely
uncomfortable so I mean that canoes is
the kind of time structure that we're
talking about but but I don't personally
know of anything hot and heavy right now
that that is progressing when it comes
in as an actual deal transpiring I look
I mean right now the whole situation to
me strikes me as radioactive you know
you've got the the trade requests
coupled with all these reports whether
they're true whether they're not you
know stuff leaking out about the
relationship between LeBron and Kyrie
Irving II you never want to deal from a
position of weakness right you never
want to you know put a guy on the market
when teams know that you have to trade
it so it makes sense to sort of pump the
brakes on this a little bit and sort of
wait till maybe late August early
September before really digging into a
deal but I guess my question Sam is is a
deal a foregone conclusion for you I
mean is there any possibility that this
could be salvaged the Kyrie Irving is
back and willing to play for this team
next year I don't see it I mean you know
this league you know you and I everybody
else who covers and learns the hard way
to never say never so those but the
think of me as you're talking about a
team that's been to the finals three
straight years that has extremely high
standards and and has a guy in LeBron
James is going to be a free agent
excimer all that means that you don't
you can't afford to to fall back and to
me having Kyrie in camp
and trying to roll the ball out with the
same group it's going to be falling back
because the chemistry and the dynamics
are going to be so bad now now listen
maybe LeBron somehow saves it and they
have a summit and they have a meeting of
the minds that they kind of put this
water under the bridge so to speak you
know I don't see it but maybe that
happens you know you've got the social
media stuff that just came out the other
day of you know Kyrie being that there's
Barnes wedding and dancing with Steph
Curry and you know and emphases and the
stuff that we're all kind of reading tea
leaves but you know Steph's doing that
dancers kind of a LeBron impersonation
and and just the optics are bad and you
know even for me when I was in Vegas and
Summerlee and a lot of people wrote
about this when LeBron shows up to see
the Sixers in the Lakers play and he's
posing for pictures with Ben Simmons and
he's hanging with you know deshante
Murray of the Spurs now we know that he
knew at that time that category was
already asking for trays and so now
those at you know that situation looks
different like he was kind of sending
his own messages so all of that makes me
feel like they've got to get a deal done
you know you can wait a little bit like
you said you can go ahead and keep
surveying the landscape until late
September but I think you got to pull
the trigger on something by then I'm
going to say I'm a member the NBA P USA
today joining me here on the Dan Patrick
show if you were Minnesota would you
have any hesitation about including
Andrew Wiggins as the centerpiece of a
Kyrie Irving trade um I mean I'd have a
hesitation because you got to think
about self life and you got to think
about the long view but I mean Kyrie is
a young man so you know I don't know
that it would be that much hesitation I
like William he's a guy that that is
already improving but when you get a guy
like Jimmy Butler and you get something
like Jamal Crawford a veteran to come in
and you got a coach like contento all of
a sudden you know you clearly you know
you're in win now mode and you've got
karl-anthony towns as a guy that is
going to be your anchor for a long time
going forward you've got that question
of Wiggins and not only do you include
them in a deal but it's somehow got
carried without it you know are you
extending Wiggins
which kind of takes cover off the table
they've got some questions to answer
there but you know that
about as good an upgrade as you are
going to find in this league you know I
don't like the parallel cinema paid to
Tobey Shaq because Carrie is not Tobey
at this point in his career but but but
in today's NBA you know he's he's about
as good a player as you're going to find
come available and there's been a lot of
that this summer you know paula jory so
you know to answer your question no I
think I would pull I would do that deal
because I think Minnesota is primed to
win right now yeah look you make a deal
for Wiggins that's one thing but you
gotta get a point guard don't you I mean
I feel like I thought there has been
somehow this perception created that
Derrick Rose is able to step in and be a
Kyrie Irving replacement I feel like
that's it's like people not watched the
last year of dirt roads in New York I
mean I'm not trying to bash the guy but
he's he's a pick and roll player who
can't shoot doesn't defend to me what do
you what are you expecting from him here
yeah yeah I mean take a deal if you
don't want to bash there just just shoot
just training as a compliment I think
the carries you know the Kyrie
compliment that the Kyrie you know
deserves better than to have people act
like there because you're going to be
able to fill that gap no problems you
know and whatsoever that's just not the
case
you know Derrick has put up some decent
numbers I'm happy for him that he's been
relatively healthy but listen the market
itself is all you got to know I mean my
God carries a max player and Derrick
Rose found himself in the position where
by the time he agreed to go to Cleveland
he didn't have much on the table and it
was one-year deals and the end of
signing a minimum so how in the world
could you process that and tell yourself
that that's a capable replacement on a
multiple time all-star and champion like
carrier so it's it's an interesting
compelling substitute then we can all
watch it and likely you see kind of the
fall off but but no I'm with you 100% I
don't think that's a calorie replacement
at all yeah hey great division with you
Sam
always appreciate the time man into
brother face Chris that's a manic
covered the NBA over at USA Today
joining me here on the Dan Patrick show
the Dan Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience